>> So, Thomas, we're here to discuss whether
India can become a
superpower.
What do you think?
>> I think it depends what you consider a
superpower is.
I mean is a superpower a country that has
military strength?
Economic strength?
Is it a country that has intellectual strength?
And if you look at all these various measures,
I think that India
already is a superpower in quite a few of
these respects.
What do you think is the most valid measure
of a superpower, when you
hear this question?
>> I guess in many ways the very idea of the
superpower is a very
Western notion.
It's something that we received almost as
part of the history of the
20th century, one that was dominated by two
Western powers, USSR and
USA, being juxtaposed against one another.
And I guess the question for me is not so
much whether India will be a
superpower, whether it can define a different
type of paradigm within
which it sees itself as a key part of the
world's structure, key part
of the world's leading countries, whatever
way that new paradigm is
defined.
>> Yeah, I think that in some ways it is already
is a superpower,
again, another aspect of this is the -- something
that has come home at
this meeting is the power of the Indian [INAUDIBLE].
Indians throughout the world, I keep meeting
Indians who come back to
Indian from very vibrant communities overseas,
and they really have
this superpower that already exists.
It's not really a case of India itself getting
things together, is that
what it is?
>> Or maybe a recognition, maybe part of what
needs to be, maybe a
different kind of label, so you don't use
the term superpower.
What kind of ways there are of describing
India?
Maybe something that comes out of this [INAUDIBLE],
something along
those lines or India's heritage.
Describe what India brings to the table.
In the same way that India did not participate
in the dynamic between
the USA and the USSR looking at the non-alignment.
Are there ways that India could define itself
differently?
But using the criteria that you talked about
earlier, which are metrics
of a country gathering on the world stage,
you know, economy, military,
social engagement, increasing social inclusion,
India definitely does
[INAUDIBLE] on world stage significant.
So I think what we're seeing is, that's sort
of a given.
It what's does that mean in terms of its way
of engagement what kind of
model does it put forward for itself?
>> All right.
So in other words, India's definitely a superpower.
We question the notion of what a superpower
is.